good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
we're coming to you live as we always do
live is more fun
but tonight with a special inside the
issues edition of the show
there are an awful lot of issues in the
news right now a lot of them are pretty
depressing so on this friday we thought
we would start with something that just
amused the hell out of us and here it is
back in 2015 our government's so-called
intelligence community which is another
intelligent nora community
announced it was embarking on a new
five-year mission
the goal according to the obama
administration was to funnel
far more resources to every spy agency
in this country and they're an awful lot
of the cia
nsa fbi dia and so on
even the coast guard's in-house
intelligence operation was slated to get
a bigger budget under this plan
now under normal circumstances an
announcement like that would set off
fear and trembling among our opponents
around the world they'd be shaking in
their caves the chinese might think
twice before bribing more harvard
professors
before sending eric swalwell a new
secret agent to have sex with
and he needs one but in this case on the
day of this announcement they just
laughed
because they knew that money was not
going to buy more drones
we weren't getting more sophisticated
surveillance equipment and more agents
in the field
no that money was earmarked for new
platoons of
equity and inclusion consultants and hr
administrators
the point of the money was to make the
intelligence community more diverse
meaning
less white and less male finally
america's spies
would look different and that is
essential if you want to
to well actually we're not sure why it's
essential
what do the race and gender of
intelligence agency employees have to do
with keeping america safe well they
never told us
instead they repeated something that we
had heard once or twice before they said
diversity is our strength
knowing our diversity
is our strength and our unity
is our power and i say to them
our diversity is our strength our
diversity
[Music]
our patchwork heritage is not a weakness
it is still and always will be
one of our greatest strengths our
diversity is one of
our greatest strengths i think this is
an opportunity
to establish that out of our diversity
comes enormous
enormous strength how does that work
exactly shut up just read the cliche
it's on the card whatever it's enormous
strength
and by that measure we are now
officially much stronger
the office of the director of national
intelligence has just released this
proof of it it's called the annual
demographic report for fiscal year 2020
hiring and retention of minorities women
and persons with disabilities
in the united states intelligence
community that's the title you're going
to want to get a copy in time for
christmas
not to read it it's not meant to be read
in fact it's unreadable
but for the pictures the pictures are
amazing there's one on the screen
we now have conclusive photographic
evidence that our spy
agencies employ several people with
different color skin
there's even a woman in a wheelchair
there's also a man who appears to be
blind
now how do we know he's blind we don't
make assumptions like that
but in this case he's got ray charles
glasses on a cane
and a seeing eye dog that seems like a
lot for one man remember
the best spies have a backup plan let's
say
russian assassins come after our blind
intelligence agent as he's
picking up a dead drop of microfilm in a
park in east berlin
somehow they managed to take out his
seeing eye dog maybe with a
it's okay he can manage because he still
has both the kane
and the ray charles glasses and by the
way we assume that kane shoots
ferrari darts at the ca they think of
everything that's their job
but what is the blind guy's job exactly
what does he do
in our fabled intel community how is he
keeping america safe we don't doubt that
he is but
how well we don't know because the
report doesn't tell us
nor does it explain why there seems to
be some sort of dark halo around the
lower part of the blind man's body in
the picture what is that exactly is it
spy vapor
another question where are all the old
people
a lot of americans are pretty old the
intel community says it's diverse
so we're the secret citizens senior
citizens where the 80 year old super
spies
you would hate to think that for all of
its famous sensitivity the biden people
fell prey to
ageism we may need a class-action suit
to sort this out and while we're at it
honestly we didn't see any trans women
non-binary pansexual two spirits or a
single person from malawi so that
picture which we greeted
with joy because of its strength is
starting to look
problematic and in fact it is
problematic
according to freelance intelligence
analysis on twitter experts on digital
manipulation
that image the one on your screen is not
real
those people were never in the same room
at the same time
some of them don't even work for the
federal government maybe none of them
the whole thing is a disinformation
campaign it's a soviet-style fake
we're serious apparently the american
intel community
spent some of its diversity budget not
to achieve diversity
but instead to buy a stock image from
the website
shutterstock the picture you just saw is
entitled quote
portrait of multi-colored cultural
office staff
standing in a lobby now you could buy
that picture too you could put on your
next christmas card if you wanted to and
maybe you should
but apparently the stock photo of
multicultural office staff
wasn't multicultural or diverse enough
for the biden people
so they inserted two other stock images
into the picture one of those stock
images is also available on shutterstock
you could buy that for your christmas
card too
it's called quite literally blind young
man with guide dog on white
background which is what it is the other
is entitled again
quite literally beautiful business woman
with tablet computer in wheelchair on
white background
huh so those aren't really intel agents
they're stock photographs from the
internet now on one level this is good
news you can make fun of it but
honestly the intel community hasn't
really outed the identity
of its most attractive wheelchair-bound
spy
or its blind double-oh-seven so they're
safe they're not going to get nabbed in
that park in east berlin
their identities have still been masked
but there are a lot of other episodes
from this lesson lessons that we
honestly are ill-equipped to diagnose
ourselves because we haven't thought
deeply enough about it and that's why we
are proud tonight
to introduce adam crowley is of course a
comedian hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else